this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
this podcast has bad words
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields melbourne
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists
[Applause]
you are so popular josh
pay them to do that
all right now if you've been following
the minimalist for a while then you've
certainly heard about our spontaneous
combustion rule one of my favorites if
not here's a refresher
pick up any item you know you own and
ask yourself
if this thing spontaneously combusted
here i'll hold up some i'll hold up my
timer here if this thing spontaneously
combusted ryan would i replace it or
would i feel relieved now of course with
this i'd replace it because we use it
every week right yeah but there are so
many things in our homes
that
are burdens and we know we wouldn't
replace them yeah even if they were free
we wouldn't replace them right should i
tell them about how the spontaneous
combustion rule came about let's talk
about it so we were in i believe it was
pittsburgh correct me if i'm wrong
you've got the memory okay i think it
was yeah and uh this this um
gal had come up to the mic and she was
like hey i've got this quilt that my mom
made me when i was 16 16 years old now
she's probably you know 25 26 27 like
she's you know way past 16 years old and
she was like it's pictures of me and my
friends and and parties we went to and
like my mom printed this these pictures
out on fabric
sewed it all together made this quilt
yeah and uh i really like it for the
memories but the problem is is i can't
really put it out anywhere because she's
not 16 anymore
and uh i just i i don't know why it just
came to me because i could see she was
burdened by it right and i was like all
right so let's say that you go home and
you find out this quilt had
spontaneously combusted how would you
feel and man like her shoulders dropped
and she was like
i feel relieved yeah and i'm like that's
a clear sign to get rid of him although
i encouraged her to donate it because
you know there's like a james franco
type character out there who would see
that in the in the thrift store and like
totally grab that and put it on their on
their couch yeah mclemore would be
really happy with that exactly yeah
and so this spontaneous combustion rule
applies obviously to our material
possessions i think it's really helpful
it's one of the 16 rules in our
minimalist rule book which you can
download for free the minimalists.com
rulebook and and you can apply these
rules loosely to your life this one in
particular it might be our favorite one
because it doesn't just apply
to our material possessions and today i
want to expand beyond the material
possessions we'll talk about that today
on this public episode we're going to
talk about the spontaneous combustion
rule for our possessions for our
friendships and also maybe even for the
city you live in or the city you feel
attached to
and this week this thursday on the
minimalist private podcast ryan we're
gonna go even deeper the spontaneous
combustion rule for careers
the spontaneous combustion rule for
social media for trends and habits for
our routines for our own identity can we
apply the spontaneous combustion rule to
the identities that we've been clinging
to also ryan i want to talk about the
relationships that you and i have blown
up over the last
decade or so oh man we're getting it
personal huh we are indeed that's this
week over on patreon that's the
minimalist private podcast completely
separate podcast we'll talk more about
that later but first since this is a
listener driven show emma we have a
question from emma not this emma even
though emma's going to read the question
it's a different emma from patreon who's
asking the question i'm confused ladies
and gentlemen emma the immigrant
when i think about some of my
friendships i realized their spontaneous
combustion would probably bring more
relief than sadness
where is the tipping point of needing to
let go of those friendships
i also do not have friendships to
replace them with at the moment so how
do you know whether or not letting go of
these friendships will benefit us
especially when faced with the potential
for increasing feelings of loneliness
once we let go
wow what what an intense question emma
i'm sorry that you are struggling with
this but
i think part of the answer at least is
in the question itself
ryan when when i read this back when i
think about some of my friendships i
realized that their spontaneous
combustion would probably bring more
relief than sadness then she asked the
question where is the tipping point well
if it would bring more relief than
sadness
then perhaps maybe it's easier to do
that with material possessions because
at first we do have some sort of
emotional tether to those but then we
realize those material possessions don't
love us back they don't like us back
they can't actually reject us
and so i can reject the possession
without it having bad feelings toward me
yeah much easier yeah but with a with a
friendship it's a little bit different
man you know my first question is if i
was emma i would ask myself why are
these relationships
uh not beneficial to me
and is there a way to reframe the
relationship set new boundaries um have
a conversation to
uh to change that relationship because i
think and we wrote about this and love
people use things like i think with
these bad relationships instead of just
looking at them and saying oh we're just
going to sever ties yes we've really got
to be honest with ourselves and ask like
hey why is the relationship the way it
is and b do i have anything to do with
it is there anything i could do
differently to make this relationship
better so that's the first thing i would
encourage i'm gonna do is dig into is
there anything that can change to make
that relationship beneficial if there's
a toxic relationship i like what you're
pointing out here sometimes i'm the
toxic part of that relationship 100
yeah
and then
the other thing too is she says that she
doesn't have friendships to replace them
with
now
if you go into the why
and you and you you know come to this
realization you're not the problem and
you have to get rid of that relationship
but you're holding on to it only because
you don't have friends to replace them
with yes you're being a dick
i don't know how else to say it but
here's how else to say it in a
compassionate way
because i know you're obviously being
compassionate there now here's the way i
look at it same thing with the material
possessions if you want to get rid of a
shirt you don't need to replace it with
another shirt right away
in fact we have this one in 10 out rule
in that minimalist rule book that we
have and so it's you could look at your
friendships the same way wouldn't i much
rather have instead of a hundred friends
that are toxic relationships that sounds
miserable yeah wouldn't i rather have
ten or five really strong friendships
that i curate even you ryan as an
extrovert who has a ton of friends
now we have three different types of
relationships in our lives primary
secondary and peripheral relationships
and really what we're talking about here
is sometimes simply re-prioritizing the
relationship if we can reprioritize the
relationship it may not be toxic anymore
and here's what i mean by that
it might mean that you're getting too
much
of a good thing
give you an example like if you just
have you know a piece of candy every
once in a while not a big deal but if
your primary diet consists of empty
calories
then all of a sudden you don't feel like
it's a treat because you're not
nourishing yourself on that and so
quite often what we're doing is we're
spending all of our time with those
people in the periphery 90 of our times
with co-workers and acquaintances and
networking buddies
and just people you
you like and it's fine that you like
them but for outlet we only have 24
hours in a day and if i'm allocating all
my time to those folks i'm accidentally
forsaking the people who align with my
values who align with my preferences the
people that i enjoy spending the most
time with and so it may not be as you
said ryan forcing them out of your life
i need this relationship to
spontaneously combust it may be that but
it also might be oh i need to
re-prioritize this i'm spending two
hours a week with this person right now
maybe i need to spend two hours a year
with this person in fact i have really
good friends that i haven't seen in two
years but whenever we reconnect we have
some of the most meaningful
conversations some of the most
meaningful experiences together because
we're not always spending every day
together yeah i think the only thing
i'll add to that is if you're holding on
to these uh toxic relationships or these
friends who you really don't want to be
friends with just because you don't have
replacements you're gonna find uh i'm
sorry you're not gonna find replacements
as fast as if you would just cut those
ties because you are like you said you
are spending two hours a week uh where
that uh instead of two two hours a year
where you could use that two hours a
week to go find new friends to go
meetup.com is amazing like you can
especially in big cities like la i mean
you can just find the most random uh the
most random groups with people who have
the same interests and uh yeah you can
also go to minimalist.org so yeah a few
years ago actually seven years ago now i
think ryan and i set up a hundred local
meetup groups in a hundred different
cities in eight different countries it's
over at minimalist.org
and uh there's also an online city so if
there is not a city close to you there
are there's over ten thousand people in
the online city as well i was going to
say i think that's our most popular city
right yeah but these places especially
pre-pandemic they were all meeting once
a month and where you were able to
connect with open-minded or sometimes
even like-minded individuals there's one
last thing i want to address for emma
here she talks about loneliness here
loneliness is not a bad thing
it's a sign
of something now sometimes loneliness is
jarring because we're so used to being
steeped in other people loneliness can
come about for one of two reasons
there's probably more than two reasons
but the first one is i feel like i need
other people
and that needing is it indicates
something that oh i'm incomplete i'm
inadequate on my own now there's this
other thing that ryan is an extrovert so
he gets his energy from other people he
doesn't need them necessarily and by the
way when you surround yourself with
people you want them to be people who
augment or enhance your life not drain
your life's energy right and so
if you need them if you show up empty
you're never going to be filled by the
relationships in your life
however if you show up full i am
adequate i am enough i know this about
me these people can augment my life they
can make my life better my experience of
life better but only if you show up full
emma you know it's interesting like i
don't feel lonely
when i don't have i mean i have a desire
to hang out with people and to have
interactions and
uh yeah to have relationships but
ultimately like i do i'm okay with being
by myself it took me a while to get
there
and why wha what were you struggling
with when you when you
you didn't want to be by yourself for a
while i think a piece of it was boredom
a piece of it was chasing that
um that excitement i get when i hang out
with people but i remember
you know when i first found out you went
to movies by yourself or like our friend
stan dukes he went to movies by himself
and i'm like
these guys are psychopaths like what is
wrong with them
but then i realized like oh no like they
are perfectly okay with being by
themselves right and uh you know i
worked on that i would go i'd have meals
by myself out at restaurants i would go
to a movie by myself and long story
short i did learn how to deal with just
being alone but not feel lonely that and
that's the key because loneliness is a
sign of something and it could be a sign
that i need to change my expectations to
not need those other people or it could
be so loneliness
could just mean that oh you know what
yes i
would like to find some empowering
relationships in my life and
yes we do have to get rid of the toxic
relationships but it's about walking
away from those relationships and
walking towards someone or some group of
people who are more empowering now don't
mistake that for needing someone to be
just like you ryan and i are like
complete opposites in almost every way
personality wise right if you look at us
at on the myers-briggs or if you look at
us on the enneagram we are radically
different human beings we just happen to
have similar values in fact on the
private podcast this week i'd like to
talk a little bit about those
personality traits and how sometimes
having different personalities sort of
yin and yang can make for a more
fulfilling relationship yeah absolutely
we have a question here from ali in cape
cod i'm living in the house that my
grandmother
um grew up in and for the most part it's
just me in this big house that's full of
stuff
um
this is a house that's been in gen
that's been in our family for
generations so there's a lot of stuff
accumulated in it um but it's not my
house and none of it really is my
possession so i was wondering what to do
when you're living in the house school
stuff that's not yours to give away
um when i realized i really can't get
rid of this stuff i was wondering if
maybe i could rearrange it
put it away put it in closets but that
doesn't work because when my parents
come they
inevitably um take everything back out
so i was just wondering
if there are any mental strategies you
can implement when you're living in an
environment that you really can't
change i can't declutter the environment
and it gets a little overwhelming
sometimes so allie here's the first
thing i think about whenever i go to the
grocery store
there's a whole lot of stuff there that
isn't mine
and quite often if i go to certain
grocery stores they're like in the
middle of chaos they're restocking
shelves they're a bunch of boxes in the
middle of the aisle
and yes because i have ocd sometimes i
feel compelled like maybe i should
straighten this up just like just get
right right next to this stock boy and
start helping you yeah hey you got to
hurry up man this is ridiculous
and and so
i i understand the impulse but if this
is not your stuff you have a couple
options here one is you might have to
move away right because even if your
parents said yes i'd love for you to
organize the house organize and it might
help out a little bit organizing is the
problem organizing often hides the
clutter and so we can go and buy all
these silly little clutter coffins from
the container store and bury our clutter
in those and and in the basement now we
have a mausoleum full of clutter coffins
but that doesn't solve the problem it
might it might calm the chaos slightly
but you know psychologically
it's all right there and that way you're
going to keep on feeling and so whenever
i'm at the grocery store there's all
this stuff everywhere or even if i have
to go to walmart for something it's
chaotic
well what do i do i go there for as long
as i need to be there and then i leave
it may be at this point it's time for
you
to exit the house move out on your own
find your own studio apartment
that you can thrive in on your own and
then whenever i go to someone else's
house it doesn't really bother me i
don't feel compelled to organize their
things because they are not my things i
don't feel compelled to get rid of their
things because they are not my things
now there may come a time in the future
where your parents say hey your grandma
stuff we don't want to deal with it or
we do want to deal with it can you help
us and if they've opened that door
then it's a completely different
conversation then we take the 16 rules
and we say all right which of these
rules apply the 90 90 rule this the
seasonality rule right the just in case
rule the just for win rule the one in 10
out rule all of these rules are going to
apply but especially the spontaneous
combustion rule is going to apply to
that stuff but right now yes you would
feel really relieved if all of it
spontaneously combusted but it's not up
to you to get rid of that stuff right
now so you may have to remove yourself
from the chaotic environment that is
making you
low-grade miserable it's stressing you
out it's overwhelming you otherwise
you're going to be steeped in stress and
anxiety yeah the low-grade miserable
isn't it funny how we put up with the
low-grade misery all the time yes and
it's usually because the low-grade
misery it isn't enough pain to actually
make us want to make a change because it
sounds like ali is living in this house
i'm assuming there's some kind of
financial benefit which is great but
there's a cost there's another cost
other than money so you're gaining
probably something financially but there
is some mental clutter there is some
emotional clutter that is definitely
being affected i mean
i think with anyone because we have high
schoolers a lot they'll be like oh my
parents are hoarders you know i'm 16
years old i have no choice yeah like i'm
living with my parents what do i do
they'll come out to our live event yeah
and ask these questions and there's no
magic bullet answer there i mean the
answer is like hey if you're living
under someone else's roof
in high school or as an adult like you
have to be beholden to their preferences
and to their roles i mean it is their
space but what you can control is your
own space so it makes me think about how
um
i don't know when we're on tour
and you go to your hotel room and you
start to like declutter it yes and you
you know you organize it or not organize
it but you get it to a point where like
you feel comfortable in that room you've
taken your space make it mine yeah and
you've made it yours um that doesn't
mean you go to every single hotel room
and do that right i wish you would come
to mind and do that though but
i could show you how yeah that'd be
great jordan we should do a video of
that we'll do it like for patreon
because we're gonna start doing these
house tours now on these studio tours
next time we're on the road we'll do a
hotel room tour because the first thing
i do when i go into a room is to make it
my my space i just unpack my bag and
i'll put it into the drawers
because
i do want it to feel more like home or
really like i want it to feel like my
space even though i'm only there
temporarily for a day or two or three
days
yeah so ally make it make your space
your own that you can
but you've got to ask yourself like what
are you willing to pay beyond finances
what are you willing to pay to stay at
this house in cape cod
uh if you're not willing to put up with
that emotional and physical yeah the
physical clutter not to mention the
emotional clutter but if you're not
wanting to put up with that then yes i
agree with you milburn maybe it's time
to find a studio apartment or or
something else yeah and you can start
with the the calm there in fact danny i
wanted to talk to you about this real
quick if you can hand danny the
microphone danny unknown he does audio
video stuff for us you've seen all the
instagram reels and the tick tocks and
and a bunch of other stuff he also takes
the photos you see on many of our
thumbnails as well but he brought some
friends he has some friends in town
recently and i'll let you tell it but
you brought them into the studio and
there was a particular kind of calm that
they
noticed
yeah we uh we just had um a meal up
there in hollywood yeah and um i was
like well we're around so let's stop by
the studio you guys can see kind of
where i work
um a couple days of the week and so i
brought them in here and
of course nothing is upset for
the podcast yeah and uh it's i mean when
it's empty in here it's beautiful right
like an art gallery yeah truly it really
is and um i opened up the windows
and then kristen who was with um jackson
and kristen were with us kristen sat and
i was like doesn't it feel good in here
and she was like
yeah it feels really like peaceful yeah
just calm and i was like
yeah that's
there's like a weight off your shoulder
because there's not a bunch of stuff
everywhere almost weighing you down
that's right yeah and so
the fast and i i get the same thing when
i have people over to my house and it's
because we don't have to organize the
stuff it's already organized because
there's less stuff there right and so if
you
have your own place you can slowly
populate it with only the things that
add value to your life and you can get
away from that chaos right because
imagine if this studio space were
similar to ali's
grandparents stuff like it would just be
a lot of stuff it wouldn't give you that
same sense it would give you the
opposite of peace
and so
whenever i show up somewhere i want to
feel that same sense of peace that's why
i do that with the hotel room it's why
we have the studio like this
it's because
any of the excess
always disturbs the peace
you could tweet that podcast sean you
know it's interesting like to have
a peaceful place
especially like uh your place here in in
la it takes a lot of work yeah it gets
easy
to just
have a lot of stuff it's actually more
difficult
to have the right about right amount of
things and to be
neat and tidy i don't know well to be
intentional about because it's it's
automatically neat and tidy if you're
constantly questioning the things you
bring into your life and you're
constantly questioning the things you're
holding on to
because this isn't serving a purpose in
my life anymore i know i i really
enjoyed it i really liked it there was a
season for that
but just like there was a season for
high school
i had to graduate from high school
i had to graduate from certain material
possessions as well and so allie maybe
it's time for you to graduate i'd love
to see you at our boston event by the
way podcast john if you could reach out
to ali and uh give her a couple tickets
to our boston event i would appreciate
that we're doing um well we're doing 11
more cities on the love people use
things tour in january and february
we'll be in new york and uh boston and
in washington dc and vancouver and
seattle and san francisco and los
angeles and toronto and columbus and
chicago and minneapolis we've already
done nine tour stops all of them are
going to be available over at
patreon.com the minimalist but you can
find tickets at theminimalists.com tour
find the city nearest you
and allie will see you out there in
boston with some special guests heck
yeah ryan what time is it it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to 937-202-4654
yes indeed now ryan and i we those texts
actually go to both of our phones it was
funny we just finished up this last
little wave of the tour in orlando and
we were in nashville in atlanta and we
had people in the audience i was just
sort of polling them hey has anyone in
here personally received a response from
me and ryan and tons of people in the
room were like yeah now we don't respond
to everyone we just can't just
logistically but we do respond to quite
a few people and so you can just send us
your text but also we answered some
questions here on the podcast now during
the lightning round that's where ryan
and i do our best to answer questions
with a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal maxims in the show notes
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if you like and
by the way thanks to our good friend
jessica you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place
minimalmaxims.com i just cleaned that up
ryan we have over 500 minimal maxims
there wow minimum maximus.com jerome has
a question this is my brother
jerome has a question for us
i often feel as though i have to blow
everything up to start over
how do we know that the desire to move
to a new place that may fit us better is
a genuine feeling and not just escapism
well here's my pithy answer for you
jerome
running toward is the opposite of
running away
so quite often
we think we can change our
surface we could change the facade the
veneer of a thing
veneer is actually a great word because
if you have rotting
teeth and you just put veneers over top
of them that actually
does it's worse for us because it hides
the problem yeah and temporarily for the
next year it might look like i have
great teeth
but now the pain sets in and it makes it
far worse because we begin to ignore the
real problem so it's it's a valid
question because escapism is a real
thing running away from our problems
they're going to follow us to wherever
we we run right however if we've
identified hey the city i'm living in is
no longer right for me for whatever
reason instead of just saying i can't
find what i want here anymore i need to
run away from this where am i going
if you want to move to a city because it
maybe serves a better opportunity for a
career maybe it's a better opportunity
for you creatively or you have a better
opportunity to in to to
submerge yourself into a different
community that shares your values that's
wonderful if you're running toward that
but if it's oh my god you know what i've
got all these problems i just need to
pack a bag and get the hell out of here
they're just gonna follow you there it
may it may not show up right away but
they're gonna follow you there
eventually yeah i mean that is a perfect
lead into my pithy answer which is you
can run from anyone except yourself and
i think about you know what i was
talking about earlier about um kind of
the superpower of being alone and being
okay with that
i could be anywhere in the world yeah
and yes like there are places i prefer
over other places
um i'm in la right now love la la's
amazing but you know i talk about
montana a lot like that's kind of where
my heart is like i eventually want to
like spend more time in montana
um but it doesn't it doesn't nag at me
yeah it doesn't ruin my day it's a
preference thing but ultimately i like
who i see in the mirror
and i could be with that guy anywhere oh
that's beautiful you could tweet that
podcast sean yeah so jerome i think the
thing to think about here ultimately
is
what are you running from and if it's
something let's deal with that first
and not just deal with it as in i'll
tolerate it but let's examine the
problem not provide you with seven
solutions but let's look at it for what
it is and then we can run towards
somewhere else that better meets your
preferences the the reason i really
enjoy los angeles is access but also the
weather i mean the weather is amazing so
it it more comports with my preferences
there because i like to walk a lot every
single day right and so having that
ability it's much more difficult if i
were to live in saskatoon to be able to
walk every day saskatoon is a fine city
i've been there there's a red lobster
there and everything
we did eat at the red lobster
well you know
we had to because like it was only there
were no mom-and-pop places it was like
like chain restaurants anyway tweet ryan
and correct him on that saskatoonians
yes that would be is that what they're
called emma
she said i think so even the canadians
don't know much are they you've never
been to saskatoon have you oh she lives
right next door to saskatoon never went
would they be saskatoons
or saskatoonies
[Music]
that sounds right we got a bunch more to
talk about
but first emma you got something for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners hey joshua
and ryan this is joe rossi i'm from
pittsburgh pennsylvania anyway i was
calling in because
recently about two weeks ago i actually
had an opportunity to watch your
documentary after listening to it get
mentioned on another podcast that i
listened to
and i was really enamored with your
message
being very reluctant initially to
jump head first into the minimalist
lifestyle i i really took an inventory
of what are the things that are drawing
me back
from living my life the way i wanted to
and really on the top of all of my lists
and in the back of my head i realized it
was my cell phone
um i don't think that using cell phones
are necessarily inherently a problem but
for me
as a dad of 10 month old twins
anything that's a distraction from my
kids is difficult because as you can
imagine we rip through formula and
diapers and all kinds of toys and fun
things all the time and if i look down
even just for one second to check
instagram notification or an email from
my boss or a text chain from my friends
something really amazing could be
happening like the first time that they
walked or
kind of scary could be happening like
they're getting into something that they
shouldn't
so i made a decision to actually switch
to a dumb phone i contacted my wireless
provider
and got my sim card chip uh replaced and
now i just have a phone that only texts
t9 like it's 2001
and makes phone calls and it really has
that small amount of minimalism really
has made a big difference in my life in
fact i was waiting in line and typically
my nose would be buried in my phone and
i had an opportunity to talk to a guy
that was behind me that had a really
neat classic truck that i saw pull into
the parking lot and uh ended up making a
friend and learning a little bit about
uh
the mechanical parts of old trucks and
stuff so
i wanted to call and say thank you
because i really appreciate it
hi my name is cecilia duffy from geneva
ohio i have a tip for minimizing and
organizing your tax records i am mostly
paperless with my taxes
make a folder on your computer with the
tax year
inside that folder you'll make other
files and folders that will hold all
your needed receipts and either an excel
or word document with a list of the tax
items by date name and amount for
instance my 2016 tax folder has the
following
number one a 2016 donation receipts
folder i scan all receipts here and
throw away the paper number two 2016
medical receipts folder again scan your
receipts into here and you can pitch
them
number three 2016 donation list this is
a word document with a list of all
donations by date place and amount at
the end of the year you just add up the
amounts
for the rest of my files i do the exact
same thing
number four is the 2016 medical list
number five 2016 charitable mileage
number six 2016 medical mileage every
time you drive related to charity and
medical it takes just a minute to put
the date place and mileage on the
documents it's much easier instead of
trying to remember every place you've
been all year long
number seven when w2s and 1099s come in
i scan and place them into aptly named
folders
number eight the last one is my property
tax receipt
taking a few minutes to scan and
document throughout the year makes tax
time much easier
as for receipts that you do not need for
tax purposes throw them away when is the
last time you needed to look at the
water bill or the grocery receipt pitch
them on the off chance you actually need
a receipt you can call the water company
and ask for it
all right so we double checked
and uh asked the almighty google and it
turns out they're called saskatoonians
it's good to know
dude inquiring minds wanted to know
canada's sunniest province i saw really
i was googling it yeah interesting we
got a bunch more to talk about this
thursday that's on the minimalist
private podcast ryan here is a
testimonial from one of our patrons over
there
joanna says my goodness this is really
hitting home i'm gonna have to listen to
this episode of the private podcast
several times because it goes straight
to the core and almost makes me cry
that's what we set out to do is make you
cry those are the money tears right
there
each private she says each private
podcast is so much more than minimalism
it's like going to 10 therapy sessions
now ryan real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalist since we're
talking about
patreon right now in our private podcast
i just want to be clear it's a
completely separate podcast we do this
this public podcast advertisement free
but our patrons keep the other the
everything that's back there on patreon
that's where we roll up our sleeves
and uh well we just get our hands dirty
our hair dirty our face is dirty
well you know it's because of our
patrons that's why this podcast right
now can be advertisement-free so if
you're not a patron um find a patron of
ours and thank them yes yes indeed you
can just you can tweet and say hey big
thanks to all of the people who do
support the podcast and we're doing some
more things to add value so of course we
do the private podcast every thursday
but we're starting to do in november
we're still working out the tech with
jordan here but we've got some new
equipment and so we're going to do a
weekly live stream as well so of the
private podcast and the public version
and also you get to see all the mess-ups
that we do and we're going to be
interacting with patrons live on the
weekly live stream we're also going to
be doing monthly home tours and studio
tours i also want to take ryan to the
container store and do a container store
tour
and so but we're also going to do like
individual rooms like let's just tour
the kitchen and look deep into the
what's going on in a minimalist kitchen
we can also look at other minimalist
homes as well so we're gonna do some
video tours for certain tiers over there
on patreon also i've been doing this
solo podcast earlier this year we're
gonna bring that back called minimalism
today and people are even asking for
ryan what and when is ryan going to do a
solo show so who knows
i'm not going to convince him but
we'll certainly talk about it i'm
handing off my work emma's now reading
the questions
i'm not trying to bring more work on
well we'll just do a cardboard cutout of
ryan
and emma will just stand behind the
cardboard cutout remember we had a
cardboard cut out for a while we were
doing this for a tour that got canceled
and we were trying to ship it out to
different people and take pictures with
us and yeah city i know we never
actually anyway we couldn't do it
because uh that particular tour the less
coast tour got canceled anyway uh you
can check all that out patreon.com the
minimalist including all of our archives
hundreds of hours of minimalism 30
biggest failures videos 50 quarantine
conversations with special guests all
that and so much more of less over on
patreon for our added value segment this
week right i want to talk about a
product that has added immense value to
my life i think it's added value to your
life as well what brand of moose are you
referring to
canadian moose
you remember moose
the hair product yeah yes oh my goodness
i used to use moose
for what i don't know
to get my little wings in the front i
should find like an eighth grade picture
of myself
that's that's why i use the moose
uh he so here's the thing about ryan he
studio audience he he
was the most awkward ugly kid
they call me snaggletooth nicodemus and
then i remember in eighth grade he hit
puberty and all of a sudden he just came
back handsome
like someone beat the hell out of him
with a handsome stick turns out it was
just a step dad beating the hell out of
him right
reshaping my face all right well he did
a great job we got to thank him yeah
thanks todd
who's todd i don't know
all right what products are you going to
recommend
so i'm not going to record i don't
recommend products okay because this may
not add value to your life at all but
this isn't your only fan's account right
no okay
so all right so i keep that private
that's my separate business
um
feet picks
anyway so we uh
you right now are standing on a
grounding mat oh yes and um there's this
company called ultimate longevity we'll
put a link to it in the show notes there
is this great book called earthing now
i'm not recommending
you go out and buy any products in fact
it doesn't even require this but
so i've had immense pain ever since we
had that whole parasitic thing i
developed this autoimmune disease if you
know anyone who has joint pain or body
pain
or is just looking to
reset their nervous system in any way
this might be for you so there's a great
book called earthing i always thought
grounding was so
woo-woo
nonsense
yeah look at these oh they just don't
want to wear shoes
bro right yeah and and so it and then i
dug into the science because of clint
ober he wrote this book called earthing
which
just changed everything i buy this book
by the case and just hand it out to
people now right because it is so
powerful and especially if you have kids
who are crying and they're little babies
who are it's quite often the thing that
will quote fix that yeah is by the
mother grounding when they hold the baby
yeah so if you go to ultimate
longevity i think it's dot com we'll put
a link to it in the show notes there's
even like a 15 minute documentary that
explains the science behind grounding
here's what happened 1960 we invented
rubber mass-produced rubber sole shoes
we inadvertently disconnected ourselves
from the earth and now we are very
rarely connected to the earth and
therefore inflammation
it travels through all it develops
throughout in our body over the years
and what i realized is oh my gosh for
almost 40 years i've barely been
grounded at all yeah and so i started
changing that in fact now i sleep on a
grounding mat at night
i get a pillow case yes
uh we stand on grounding mats here in
the studio i even plug in i use these
little patches that to plug into the
grounding as well you just plug into the
grounding of the wall you have to have a
grounded outlet so you can test it it
comes with a little tester dude if it
wasn't for you i never would have tried
i would have looked at it still been
like what
what is this crazy thing like plugs into
the wall right you stand on yeah anyway
or you sleep on you have to put on top
of your sheets and yeah literally like
my so we have the oar rings that keep
track of our sleep my sleep has gotten
10 to 20 percent better
since just grounding which blows my mind
and i'll tell you what's really nice
about not doing advertisements and being
paid for things like this like you know
that we're like telling the truth like
you know it's something we actually use
ourselves and yeah totally recommend the
one thing i'll say about this man is
that if someone is interested in this
what i really like about uh what they do
is when you get like a grounding mat or
something they give you a free book with
it
which is kind of cool yeah and so here's
the other thing to think about though
you don't have to spend a dime you can
go grounding on the beach or just go
walk on grass 100 correct yes and so
it's impossible if if you're grounded to
also experience inflammation the same
way as if you're not grounded and that
so if you're in pain
for me at first within 24 hours of
beginning to ground my pain reduced by
10 to twenty percent within six to ten
weeks my pain reduced by eighty percent
and this is why grounding has been it's
literally changed my life and i've
waited a long time to talk about this on
an added value segment because i want to
make sure that the results lasted for a
while and i mean i ground every day i'm
grounded 90 of the day now
either on a grounding mat or while
sleeping or just walking barefoot on the
beach or outside or even walk to the
studio from from my apartment here i'll
walk through people's yards barefoot
yeah and it has totally changed my life
but you don't take my word for it you
can check out free documentary at all
ultimate longevity and as ryan said we
don't get paid for any of this in fact
we pay full price for anything that we
we purchase as well yeah no i'm glad
that you uh brought up the free aspect
of grounding you do not need a grounding
mat right to ground
literally just go walk barefoot in the
grass
what do they say the best is um
like salt like wet sand because it has
salt water on there or something about
the salt that does like extra grounded
and uh i think it was bex who was like
maybe that's why surfers are so laid
back yeah because they're just cause
being in the ocean is the best form of
grounding yeah because there's so many
minerals there as well yeah you can
learn so much more in the book earthing
or just
ultimatelongevity.com we'll put a link
to all of that in the show notes by the
way ryan we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like what are nine
ways to avoid spending money on trendy
items i'm going to talk about my black
t-shirts this week what brand does josh
use
if i get i've had a dollar for some time
someone messaged me on instagram asked
me about my black t-shirts i would have
hundreds of dollars how do you stop
searching for the perfect thing we're
gonna talk about that on the private
podcast as well how do i make my boss
spontaneously combust what about my
family what about my social media habits
plus a million more questions about
letting go for the minimalist if you
want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast this week
visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalists come to one of our live
podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com tour to find a city
near you if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com the
minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at the
minimalists.com you'll also receive our
simple sunday email newsletter for free
if you live here today with just one
message
let it be
this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it